[Music]
in the film that we're gonna talk about
proof they'll station you had a beard
but you said that it took you and and
not even a just a little more than you
have now we don't have to labor have to
bring that up right now well I'm going
to because I'm fascinated by this topic
but you but but I read somewhere that
you you had trouble growing the beard it
took a while ok I can't I can't I can't
grow a beard I can't really connect I
mean it's a little patchy there are
parts where it doesn't grow the dandy
has that part I don't you that I can
grow it here and then there's a few
hairs waving down there I mean women I
mean doesn't don't guys do everything
for women for the most part yes every
single balls everything that I did for
the first 30 years of my 30 40 years of
my life was all designed towards getting
a woman that's all right yeah so during
my research you know women like that
little stubble that that new growth that
dangerous look that you know he might
choke me up I don't know I couldn't I
couldn't I couldn't pull that look off
so I think this is all I can do they
should make a spray they should quit
stubble on your face on a beard just sit
up oh we should be a stubble spray I'm
come padding that I'm taking that
passion now what about your back you got
a lot of hair on the back no no I have
hair nowhere in my body except my back
oh really
just a strip down the mark no one
understands what's going on got the
landing strip I don't want to talk about
this anymore
[Music]
I got a change tone now but for a good
reason
Fruitvale station this is an extremely
powerful movie you are brilliant in the
film
and it is a it is a true story and and
it's it took place in 2009 2009 true
story and well why don't you set it up
because it's such a powerful story Oscar
Grant Oscar Grant this kid from from
Oakland California and he was handcuffed
face down shot in the back by the BART
Transit Police on New Year's Day and the
movie takes place over the last 24 hours
of his life it was a very eventful day
it was his mom's birthday it was New
Year's and he spent a lot of time with
the people that he really cared about
his daughter his girlfriend and all his
best friends and um you know I said I
love Ryan cuckoo's approached the to the
film because he's a director at the
writer/director because it gives you the
day in the life of you know sometimes
you know when these incidents happen all
the time they're a blurb in the
newspaper you don't really know much
about the person whatsoever you know but
this this way you spend a day in the
life of you know if I could wake up in
the morning with you and spend the
entire day go out through go throughout
your daily routine I can get a pretty
good idea who you are as a person and
your character and that's what you
should be judged on well but what I
thought it's exactly what you're saying
the movie begins it's quite powerful but
there were witnesses there who had their
cell phones out who are recording and
and so you see this young man and a few
other young men being detained and then
you see this whole thing happened very
shocking things get out of control
quickly and then as you said it's a
story in the news and sadly a story we
hear to off exactly what happens then is
you guys make the me the viewer and
anyone who watches the movie get to know
Oscar Grant as a person as a person and
you really care about him to the point
where at the end of the movie I had to
go back and just went back to see the
the documentary footage at the very
beginning and it just made it's so
powerful it's so properly so well done
you you are brilliant in this move
we have a clip here from Fruitvale
station I think this is a fight that
takes place on the BART line the train
right before right before the it
precipitates all the trouble afterwards
let's take a look hey hey
hey Katie from the start hey how are you
good I'm good
Happy New Year Happy House good for
policy
asking what's up it's gonna get
Christmas
all right
[Applause]